ciertamente es más exitosa que las
primeras 48 horas y el periodo sobre
todo de marzo observamos de que rusia ha
logrado tener avance en el sur oeste de
ucrania a pesar de que todavía hay mucha
incertidumbre respecto si es posible
mantener el sobre estiramiento que ha
tenido durante todo abril desde el punto
de vista de cadena logística y cadena de
suministro no cabe ninguna duda de que
la caída de mario pool es un evento
relevante tanto desde el punto de vista
militar como desde el punto vista
simbólico y es posible que su empuje a
nuevos avance de la federación rusa en
conquista o al menos en ocupación
territorial en la zona este de ucrania
pero recientes referidas precisamente a
esto pero te lo quiero preguntar de
manera más concreta no que representa
esta caída de mariupol es realmente una
victoria para moscú o por el contrario
cree que quizás le dio más tiempo a los
ucranianos para organizarse en otras
regiones del país
yo creo que tiene esa doble lectura por
un lado es una ciudad que mediante su
resistencia logra desgastar a la fuerza
rusa desde una perspectiva sobre todo
los primeros dos meses y ese desgaste ha
traído consecuencias de orden política
pero por otro lado al mariupol es la
ciudad que conecta directamente al mar
de azov y de ahí al estrecho de kerch
que es básicamente la ruta que hay que
tomar para llegar al mar negro por ende
desde el punto de vista geopolítico y
estratégico la toma de poder de la
federación rusa creo que es más
importante que el desgaste que ella
experimentó durante los primeros dos
meses vamos a hablar un poco más no de
las implicancias de la caída de mariupol
sobre todo de cara al avance de los
rusos hacia o de esa verdad en términos
del eventual bloqueo no de este puerto
naciones unidas- recordemos está
advirtiendo de una crisis alimentaria
global con la las perturbaciones a las
exportaciones
no cabe ninguna duda es muy preocupante
y es muy significativo es avance en
parte porque el efecto es de carácter
global puede existir también una
decisión estratégica por parte de las
fuerzas armadas ucraniana de que
aquellas fuerzas de resistencia mariupol
tiendan a trasladarse hacia el oeste
particularmente en jacob e incluso más
allá en odesa entonces es cierto de que
las fuerzas ucranianas no son infinitas
requieren ser utilizadas con
inteligencia y también existe esta
especie de preocupación a nivel mundial
creo que eso también va de la mano con
los anuncios de europeo y también de
estadounidense de proporcionar mayor
cantidad de ayuda económica precisamente
porque el grado de relevancia en eslabón
alimentario para todo el mundo es muy
significativo si es que se guía a
controlar el puerto de esa ahora yo
hablamos de la toma de lugar también del
anuncio de dejar de defender la asediada
ciudad de mariupol cómo evaluás la
contraofensiva ucraniana
creo que así una ofensiva que ha tenido
altos y bajos recordemos por ejemplo al
inicio la resistencia que hubo sobre
quiere que fue una resistencia bastante
heroica y también sobre jarquín no hay
que olvidar de que las tierras suelen
ser enormemente plásticas por lo tanto
no hay que concebir que lo que estamos
viendo hoy en el presente vaya a
mantenerse en el tiempo sobre todo
porque hemos observado la mutación del
conflicto durante todo este último
periodo si sumamos las ofensivas que ha
tenido ucrania en el norte sobre todo
del país las ayudas de europa y de eeuu
más el desgaste la federación rusa nada
está dicho aún respecto del control
territorial en el este por parte de
rusia todavía queda mucho de guerra y no
hay que sorprenderse si esta guerra
continúa e incluso hasta finales de este
año